What's up guys, my name is Colin McNeil from theScore esports
You know there's just something special about a grand final on LAN.
There's energy in the air, the stakes are high, the crowd is loud.
It's the place where CS:GO legends, are born.
Sometimes.
It's also the place where rosters can collapse, where dynasties go to die.
Where hopes and dreams at glory can fade away.
With that diverse criteria in mind, here is our list
of the Top 10 most impactful and memorable CS:GO grand finals of all time.
Starting things off at number 10 is Fnatic’s return
to glory at IEM Katowice 2018, where they
managed to win their first premier championship
in two years.
It took seven hours, five maps, 149 rounds,
three overtimes and two ace clutches from
flusha to beat the star-studded lineup of
FaZe Clan.
[Casting]
But in the end, it was Swedes lifting the
hardware, remembering what it felt like to
win again.
[Casting]
No one predicted this grand final between
underdogs Gambit and the second best CS:GO
team from Brazil, Immortals.
This Grand Final was incredible for so many
reasons.
Zeus fulfilled a promise he’d made a year
prior to win a motherf***ing Major, Dosia
gave us an unforgettable grenade play
[Casting]
and Gambit made history as the first CIS team
to win a Major.
[Casting]
It was DreamHack Montreal 2017.
Immortals were forced to forfeit the first
map of their best of three grand final against
North after three of their players showed
up late to the match.
(Casting)
North won what would be the first
and only map of the finals in an anticlimactic
win that robbed viewers of the clash of Counter-Strike
titans they had been promised.
(Casting)
FNS would take to Twitter and
remarked that the Immortals players were late
due to partying too hard the night before.
Whether it was purely in jest or not, one
Immortals player in particular did not take
the comment lightly.
In response to that, was the tweet that shocked
the CSGO community and eventually broke up
Immortals:
FaZe Clan entered the finals of IEM Oakland
2017 as a heavy favourite
Ninjas in Pyjamas had taken the entire tournament
by surprise by making it to the finals, but
nobody expected they’d actually be able to
beat FaZe.
Well, they did.
With some crafty play and a lot of aggression,
it was Get_Right, f0rest, REZ, Xzit and draken
who defied the odds and put on a grand final
that reminded us why NiP are legends
in Counter-Strike.
[Casting]
At DreamHack Leipzig in 2016 Luminosity Gaming
showed that Brazilian CS:GO should be taken
seriously by finishing in second place for
the second consecutive big event.
"They were better than us at some times. Yeah, hard game and well played to them."
Then, at MLG Columbus they solidified that
fact when they crushed NaVi 16-2 in the final
map of the tournament taking home their
first big title win
[Casting]
For a long time Astralis entered every
Major tournament as one of the favourites
— but could never quite get the job done.
The first ELEAGUE Major would break that curse
for Astralis when they defeated Virtus.Pro
in spectacular comeback fashion.
[Casting]
The grand final of Katowice 2015 saw two
of the biggest juggernauts in esports
go toe-to-toe for a Major championship.
The series was well-fought and NiP pushed
it to a third map
[Casting]
But they just didn't have what it took to defeat Fnatic on Inferno.
Our Number 3 Grand Final harkens back to the
beginning of Luminosity’s legacy, which
actually started in crushing defeat at DreamHack
Open Winter 2015.
[Casting]
The defeat at the hands of Fnatic would mark the
the beginning of the Swedish CS juggernaut’s
new run with dennis replacing pronax.
[Casting]
In 2015 at ESL One Cologne Fnatic put a stamp
on one of the most dominating runs in the
history of CS:GO.
The Swedes defeated EnVyUs in a decisive
two consecutive
maps to win their third Major title.
[Casting]
With this win, that Fnatic roster may have
cemented themselves as the best team in CS:GO
history.
It may have only ended less than two months ago, but this one was an instant classic.
Nowhere near the favorites headed into the
tournament, Cloud9 were set to take on EU
powerhouse FaZe Clan.They came from behind
in the final map of the Grand Finals on the
back of incredible mental resilience and veteran-like
play to push the tournament-favorite Faze
Clan to double-overtime and eventually make
history.
[Casting]
We'll be talking about this one for a long time to come.
[Crowd chanting] USA! USA! USA!
Well guys, that was our list. But if you think we missed a CS:GO grand final
That should have been in this top 10, I don't know what to say, go make your own list or something.